hello and welcome back to the lab where
we take your questions and turn them
into experiments my name is Mitch and
I'm Greg and what if I told you that
there was a list of questions that could
make you fall in love with a stranger
well it turns out there was actually a
study done where they took a specific
set of 36 questions had two complete
strangers asked them to each other and
it increased the likelihood that they
would fall in love and obviously in
general just doing one experiment
doesn't prove anything but we thought it
would be awesome to get two strangers in
here forced them to do this experiment
and see what happened so this is what
happened
my name is cam and I'm 24 my name is
Emily and I'm 22 years old I'm nervous
about today to be perfectly honest I
really want to see if the study works I
think we'll be you know what if we hate
each other or we don't like what we're
saying I I think it would be cool to see
if it's effective hey how's it going
great how are you good Emily right yeah
nice to meet you too are you nervous at
all for this yes yeah me too we can just
get started so the first question given
the choice of anyone in the world whom
would you want as a dinner guest
instinctually I want to say Clint
Eastwood yes I would say probably like
Neil Armstrong or something like that I
think I would like to be famous I guess
not an a-list celebrity or anything like
that maybe a delist one where some
people know who you are you know you'd
be that guy nice song to myself on the
car right over here I was listening to
Taylor Swift nice what's on the hole out
oh nice
like fearless not even her new stuff so
they're keeping the questions pretty
light as you could see you used to think
I was gonna die really young like in
high school when I was angsty I was like
I'm gonna be that I'm gonna be that's
gonna happen but then I hit 18 and I was
like forget that Emily you're gonna live
to a hundred you're making this entry
club I've always wanted to be a good
artist I'd like to be maybe a bit more
assertive like maybe not too much so
though I want to push people and be
doing anything we don't want to do my
most terrible memory was the morning my
sister called me to tell me what my mom
had had a heart attack yeah she's okay I
it's good that she's okay but I can
imagine that is terrifying she's doing
she's I would say mine would be when my
grandma's mine just kind of started
deteriorating because she lived with us
for mmm my whole life you know to see
her forget who I am and you know call me
a different name and she would wake up
some days and you know and she's a 90
year old woman and wonder why she didn't
have school that whole part is pretty
terrible I would say so yeah I know
people need affection in I do too but I
have to like more think about sometimes
my actions people need validation
sometimes and they need to hear that or
see you by touch stuff like that
romantic love hasn't hasn't been a big
role in my life for the past a little
over a year now I'm trying to be a bit
more cautious about who I give and
receive that love from because it is so
important I have a stuffed animal Buster
he's a dog so I probably might save
Buster mine's fluffy ok monster fluffy
should meet one day yeah I was worried
about this coming into it because I
can't be a little bit awkward but you
make me feel at ease you know you seem
very cool and calm and confident at the
same time so I guess that's three but
yeah you have a good personality I also
like what you're wearing
thank you those colors really compliment
you um I like your face it's a nice face
your face is great symmetrical which is
something we subconsciously look for but
because I know that I consciously look
for I say like a lot like like this like
that but you're very very well spent
I actually swear alt time I'm trying
really hard shit
curse like a sailor yeah it would be
nice to have someone that you could
literally say anything and everything
and they would still like you and
respect you and not think you're a big
weirdo you were very very nice smile I
would definitely make it with you okay
yeah I was kind of thinking about that
like on our break I was like yeah I
would definitely make it with him yeah I
think he's pretty attractive we have a
lot of things in common and I like what
I like thinking I think it's a good
thing that you know
be a lot more awkward but it was it was
more just exciting mm-hmm
I like you you're cool yeah thank you
yeah it was interesting getting to know
a lot about you cuz a lot of those
questions are necessarily stuff you'd
say right away or even sometimes ever to
someone sure sounds good